thank you very much for joining us a
Pegasus Airlines flight has skidded off
the runway while landing at one of his
stumbles main airports Turkish
authorities say all 171 passengers and
six crew members on board survives
fifty-two are injured and have been
taken to hospital the Boeing 737 was
landing at Sabiha gökçen Airport when it
crashed splitting into three parts it
was traveling from the Turkish city of
Izmir let's get the latest from Hashim
al bara who's in Istanbul for us so
Hashem tell us about what's been
happening and have all the passengers
been removed from the airplane they have
the India they have been removed from
that plane and the 53 who were injured
at the moment of the crash was sent to
hospitals in Istanbul to be treated
however investigators are now trying to
determine exactly what happened at the
moment when the plane was touching down
because what happened later was
basically the plane veering off the
runway bursting into flame and breaking
into three pieces and they are trying to
establish whether there was any
mechanical problem that led to this
crash or this was related in a way or
another to bad weather conditions
strong winds were reported at the very
same time when the plane were attempting
to touch down at the Sabiha gökçen
airport so this is exactly I think what
they are investigators and the
authorities are trying to look into with
more details to come up with more
clarity about what happened to the
Boeing 737 right a lot of questions in
indeed what impact has this had on
operations at Sabiha go chain Airport
the authorities have closed the airport
and then redirected most of the flights
to neighboring airports in Istanbul and
I think they are trying at this
particular moment to ensure that
everything is under
trol and before making any decision in
the near in the coming hour they would
like to establish exactly whether this
was a technical failure or related to
weather conditions so this explains why
they are taking all those pre-emptive
and measures but I have also to remind
our viewers that the same low-budget
company Pegasus Airlines suffered a
similar incident about a month ago when
one of its airplanes slid off the runway
at the Sabiha gökçen Airport and then
the investigators established later that
this was related to poor weather
conditions then okay Hashem thank you
for that update hashem i have our ally
for us any sample let's speak some more
about this our to aviation specialist
Alex Machaerus who joins us here on the
news aisle good to have you with us on
al Jazeera Alex plane slide off the
one-way often but they don't break up in
two or three pieces as is a case here
it's a be her Airport what do you think
happened here well this aircraft has
today suffered quite a dramatic runway
excursion and that's the real name for
what this aircraft has been involved in
so this is a Boeing 737 operated by the
Turkish low-cost carrier Pegasus and
ultimately there are variety of factors
that can lead to the inability to bring
the aircraft to a safe stop at the end
of the runway this is actually not the
first time this aircraft and this
airline have suffered with such a wrong
way excursion at this airport in
Istanbul severe and of course the
investigation this initial period will
focus firstly on the search and rescue
and that's rescuing those who have been
caught up in this accident and then of
course preventing any future or further
potential incidents if for example the
runway was contaminated right how
difficult is it for a pile pilot rather
to keep control of a plane on a Reyn a
runway or pilots are incredibly well
trained and ultimately act travel
continues to be the safest form of
transport an aircraft is taking off or
landing every one-and-a-half seconds and
so it's a you know what why there should
be no question over the potential
difficulty of this specific airport for
example but actually it's more likely to
be like I said one of those external
factors for example weather now the
weather right now as we have seen in the
footage in Istanbul it's very windy
their self
a lot of rain a contaminated runway for
example a wet runway could lead to added
complexity during the landing and during
the phase of that landing where their
flight crew are having to bring that
aircraft to a full stop yeah as you
mentioned this is not the first incident
involving Pegasus Airlines at that same
airport in a month I think it was last
month in January there was a similar
incident how safe is this airline what's
her safety record
well Pegasus are known predominantly for
their low fares and ultimately it would
be unfair to brand them as unsafe just
because they they do offer very
competitive fares but there will be
serious questions asked now given that
this airline has suffered now its second
runway excursion in just four weeks at
the same airport and quite famously in
2018 it suffered another dramatic runway
excursion in Trabzon in is in in Turkey
where the fuselage was broken into two
today's incident the actual fuselage
broken into three pieces very dramatic I
hear that investigators are already on
their way
including from the u.s. to determine
exactly what has happened and then to
draw up that initial investigation yeah
and Alex I can't help but note that this
is a Boeing 737 obviously something that
Boeing doesn't need right now this extra
publicity bad publicity that they don't
need for viewers it may seem like Boeing
can't catch a break at the moment with
all of this publicity surrounding the
737 but especially in this circumstance
with it just being a runway excursion
there should be no question over the
safety Boeing 737s remain incredibly
safe worldwide they are the workhorse of
the fleet not to be confused with the
troubled and grounded 77 Maxim thank you
so much Alex for shedding some light on
this Alex my chair is an aviation
specialist join me next year on al
Jazeera thank you for your time